bonjour monsieur edouard balladur se
présente pour la première fois à la
présidence de la république monsieur
brice lalonde pour la deuxième fois
monsieur chirac pour la troisième est
notre invité d'aujourd'hui pour la
quatrième fois
madame la guye et bonjour vous êtes
candidate du parti trotskiste lutte
ouvrière parti d'extrême gauche
vous faites preuve d'une belle
persévérance car vous êtes la
recordwoman des candidatures et d'une
belle constance dans vos convictions qui
n'ont pas varié d'un pouce depuis que
vous militez à lutte ouvrière c'est à
dire depuis 1968
vous êtes donc à la fois je dirais
inoxydable à l'usure du temps et
imperméable aux modes qui joue pourtant
vous le savez un si grand rôle en
politique jusqu'à présent cette
persévérance daguerre payer en 74 obtenu
2,30 3% des suffrages exprimés en 1980 2
32% en 88 vous êtes tombée à 2,2 pour
cent mais de 0 2% et mais cette fois ci
ça a l'air de marcher assez fort pour
vous à dans le sondage ifop du journal
du dimanche de ce matin vous êtes à 85%
14,7 vote c'est-à-dire dix fois le
candidat du parti radical monsieur ory
alors est ce que vous serez encore
candidate est ce que vous serez encore
candidate en 2002 année où monsieur
balladur aura 3 où vous aurez vous trois
ans de moins que monsieur balladur
aujourd'hui je le dirai peut-être à la
fin de l'émission
d'accord on veut leur posera alors bien
sûr vous allez ce matin nous parler de
votre programme madame de ce que vous
proposez aux français mais nous vous
êtes rejoint aussi sur l'actualité qui
est particulièrement riche cette semaine
vous qui avez publié en 88 un livre
intitulé il faut changer le monde
qu'est ce que vous pensez du programme
de lutte contre la pauvreté adopté
vendredi à copenhague par les nations
unies par les chefs d'état des nations
s'il y est vous qui pour employer
l'expression un peu familière bouffer du
patron à longueur de discours
que pensez-vous des malheurs de ce soir
pdg d'alcatel thompson contraint par la
justice a abandonné ses fonctions à la
tête du deuxième groupe industriel
français ses mésaventures d'ailleurs
inspiré le dessinateur plantu
vous l'avez vu dans le monde d'hier avec
cette phrase est en plus arlette
laguillier passe à l'heure de vérité
alors on va diviser cette émission en
trois parties si vous en êtes d'accord
avec christine clerc du figaro magazine
nous essaierons de faire plus ample
connaissance avec vous dans le who's who
ce dictionnaire de la réussite sociale
consacrée par la bourgeoisie
vous vous présentez comme femme
politique mais vous êtes aussi entre
deux élections il faut le dire employés
au crédit lyonnais
on en parlera et vous cette femme tout
court et nous essaierons de retrouver la
femme derrière la militante et derrière
la candidate
alors on parle ensuite avec jean marie
colombani de votre programme qui est le
même que la dernière fois
puis avec alain duhamel de vos
adversaires qui eux ne sont plus les
mêmes si j'excepte monsieur richter
monsieur chirac et monsieur le pen alors
on commence tout de suite avec christine
clerc pour un petit quart d'heure estime
claire du figaro magazine et juillet à
reggio vous l'a dit il m'a chargé
d'interroger chez vous la femme et de
laisser la politique mes collègues
masculins
peut-être même une question un peu
politique nous même bizarre d'avoir
choisi son anneau ça arrive souvent que
c'est un peu politique qui me turlupine
vous êtes quelqu'un de gentil je crois
vous aimez les gens et ya pourtant une
catégorie que vous ne pouvez pas en
crise et ce sont les patrons
alors si vous aviez un collègue salariés
au crédit lyonnais où un ou si oui un
jeune chômeur qui en vue de créer son
entreprise qu'est une bonne idée qu en
vue de créer des emplois vous lui dites
non ne tient pas patron tu ne seras plus
mon ami vous savez si je connais un
jeune dans mon milieu qui veut devenir
patron
je lui dirai attention les il vaut bien
mieux peut-être que tu restes avec tes
camarades de travail a essayé de changer
cette société pour que demain tout le
monde puisse avoir un niveau de vie
décent avoir le droit à un logement
avoir le droit à l'éducation avoir le
droit à la culture avoir le droit d
souhaitent à des soins correct à une
retraite correcte je lui dirai que
l'avenir c'est ça aujourd'hui c'est
collectivement ne changions la société
pas d'essayer de s'en sortir
individuellement en montant sur l'épaule
des autres puis je lui dirai en plus que
c'est pas certain qu'ils aient la chance
de tapis d'avoir des soutiens politiques
et le soutien des banques
1 vous n'avez pas essayé de vous en
sortir un miaulement pourtant je crois
vous était une bonne élève à l'école
vous auriez pu comme on dit gravir les
échelons devenir peut-être un cadre qui
sait peut-être un directeur d'agencé
bancaire
vous avez préféré adopter le opté pour
le combat politique
vous savez quand vous appelle
quelquefois une bonne soeur laïque dans
ma bouche c'est pas c'est pas
désobligeants d'ailleurs vous vous
maquillez pas sauf un tout petit peu
aujourd'hui je croise pour la première
fois vous n'avez pas voulu vous marier
ni avoir d'enfant vous êtes consacrer
entièrement au combat pour les autres
quand est ce que ça vous est venue cette
vocation à quel moment avez vous
prononcer cette espèce de voeux comme
d'autres prononce le voeu de pauvreté et
chasteté
moi j'ai pas de vocation particulière je
suis d'une génération qui avait 14 ans
début de la guerre d'algérie et cette
guerre d'algérie la jeunesse de mon
époque nous a profondément marqué et si
je me suis engagé en politique c'est
pour soutenir la lutte d'indépendance du
peuple algérien comme beaucoup de jeunes
gens et jeunes femmes à l'époque est
très très naturellement je dirais
presque
ce combat là ma portée vers l' envie de
militer de faire plus pour changer
complètement la société moi qui faisais
partie d'un milieu modeste pauvres on
peut dire et qui donc avait connu
beaucoup d'injustices déjà
dans son enfance et qui cherchait la
façon que la société marche mieux qu'ils
aient pas d'un côté comme on le voit
aujourd'hui de façon flagrante une
richesse énorme à un bout et de plus en
plus de pauvres à l'autre dans votre
livre moi une militante vous racontez
votre enfance vous dites que votre père
avait été séminariste et que votre mère
était très catholique
qu'est ce qui vous en est resté cette
éducation religieuse sur le plan de la
religion rien du tout d'heure je veux
dire que j'ai jamais cru même étant
enfant j'ai tu es là contestataires du
catéchisme et non j'ai jamais cru mais
mon père justement peut-être parce qu'il
avait fait ce type d'étude avait
complètement changé et est au contraire
un laïcat athée convaincu qui m'a plutôt
transmis son virus film alors
apparemment vous n'avez jamais été non
plus tenté par le mariage et vous en
parlait assez sévèrement on vous dit que
autour de vous vous voyez tellement de
coupe qui n'ont rien à se dire qui se
borne à regarder la télévision vous
plaignez ces pauvres femmes qui ont qui
ont cru à l'amour une invention de la
littérature bourgeoise des doux et qui
se retrouve finalement enchaînés aux
tâches ménagères et à l'éducation des
enfants
donc il faut pas se marier c'est ce que
vous savez premièrement je crois que mes
idées ne sont pas très original
aujourd'hui si j'en juge par les
statistiques
il ya beaucoup plus de couples qui
vivent ensemble sans être mariés que
l'averse et ça semble se développer pour
une fois dira pas que j'ai des idées
ringardes on dira que j'ai des idées de
notre époque
non je crois que moi je rêve d'une
société où justement les changes entre
les individus soient riches et et où la
vie sociale se cantonne pas à la cellule
familiale qui d'ailleurs souvent se
défait et c'est vrai que je connais
beaucoup de femmes qui élèvent seules
des enfants aujourd'hui qui ont des
difficultés et le problème pour ces
femmes et ç'a toujours été mon idée en
tout cas moi c'est que les femmes
puissent être indépendante
économiquement et ne dépendent pas d'un
homme pour cela et je suis pour le droit
au travail
femmes le droit ce qu'elles puissent à
la fois réalisé une vie professionnelle
une vie sociale et en même temps élever
des enfants
mais que ce soit l'ensemble de la
société qui les aide justement à cette
tâche d'élever les enfants
mais l'amour vous n'y croyez pas c'est
vraiment une invention la littérature
bourgeoise pour vous on la voit pas et
j'ai lu vous n'avez pas vu autour de
vous non mais je crois que si l'amour
éternel était comme ça une vérité en
soit il y aurait pas autant de divorces
ne vous croyez pas n'importe où de
littérature chez elle et chez vous j'ai
été très frappé par le nombre de livres
que vous avez et surtout par votre
collection de lénine et trotsky il ya 43
volume de lénine et 24 de trotski autre
chose comme ça c'est curieux de voir
quelqu'un qui lit lénine à l'époque où
on le déboulonne en russie qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire
autour de vous pour inciter à lire
lénine
qu'est-ce qui est encore à retenir de
les lignes d'abord je crois que pour moi
la révolution russe de 1917 c'était la
seule révolution ouvrière prolétarienne
qui existait en fait dans ce monde et
que lénine qui en était un des acteurs
principaux après l'avoir préparée a
beaucoup de choses à nous apprendre et à
nous dire sur toute cette époque toute
la russie sur les idées des
révolutionnaires sur pourquoi la
révolution russe a finalement été
possible et aujourd'hui il est de bon
ton pour des gens qui on se disait
communiste qui en fait était stalinien
et soutenait le régime stalinien de
jeter marx lénine trotsky aux orties
mais pour moi c'est pas ça du tout pour
moi au contraire les acteurs de cette
révolution sont les sols finalement qui
nous explique et qui en réalité avait
prévu l'échec de cette révolution qui a
eu lieu dans un pays développé où la
classe ouvrière était faible et qui ne
pouvait qu'échouer dans la mesure où le
reste des travailleurs en particulier
des pays développés de l'europe ne
suivait pas l'exemple de la révolution
tout ça c'est dans lénine ce qui est
terrible de maj abl aujourd'hui pour la
classe ouvrière du monde entier et bien
que c'est que des intellectuels
finalement et soutenu le régime
stalinien
pendant toute une époque et aujourd'hui
rejette le bébé avec l'eau de la
baignoire grande moi je me revendique de
cette ré vous avez grandi aux lilas et
vous vivez toujours aux lilas vous
parlez de la russie je peux vous êtes
allé une fois jamais et ils n'aident pas
les aux etats-unis non non vous avez
très peu voyagé
est ce que comme des millions de
salariés qui doivent gagner leur vie
quand en plus on fait de la politique
sur ses temps de loisirs est ce qu'on
perd on a moins forcément le temps de
voyager ou peut être candidat à la
présidence de la république sans
connaître un peu le monde
vous savez je prétends que par mes
lectures par mes contacts avec des
militants d'autres pays je prétend
connaître aussi bien le monde que des
gens qui vont recevoir des cadeaux quand
ils vont en visite dans un pays étranger
ne voit pas la population ne voit pas la
réalité sont dans des palaces je sais
pas par exemple au brésil et voit pas la
misère qui les entoure
moelleux le sort du monde y mater racim
passionne au plus haut point si je suis
révolutionnaire c'est parce que j'ai
envie de changer le sort de l'humanité
dans le monde entier vous lisez beaucoup
vous allez au théâtre par contre j'ai
cru comprendre que vous trouvez la
télévision c'est pas c'est pas votre
truc et le tiercé vous trouvé ça très
aliénant alors quel dialogue pouvait
voir voir avec les gens justement qui
habitent les
il a autour de vous les gens du crédit
lyonnais qui regardent la télévision
joue au tiercé
comment je reviens quand on y regarde
pas commune comme julien télé je regarde
la télévision tout à fait j'en discute
je suis très critique mais ça c'est mon
droit puis je suis pas là ça je crois et
bien sûr que je discute de tout ça avec
mes camarades de travail
ah bah non je joue pas au tiercé moi je
je suis pas pour que on et désillusions
ni dans la vie ni en politique je suis
pour qu'on consciemment on agisse sur
les événements et je pense que la classe
ouvrière
elle a les moyens la force pour peu
qu'elles en soient convaincus d'agir sur
les événements et changer les choses et
c'est à sa conscience à laquelle je fais
appel quels sont vos moments de bonheur
dans la vie c'est chez veine la destine
surtout mes camarades là tout de suite
de les voir s'amuser la rieuse
c'est la grande famille de la carlingue
la camaraderie oui vous savez je c'est
important quand on milite on connaît
vraiment la fraternité militante
ça manque pas mal dans cette société
mais il ya des enfants dans votre vie je
crois que vous occupez d'enfants deux
neveux deux nièces de j'adore les
enfants
je milite pour changer le monde pour les
enfants parce que justement je les aime
les enfants
alors bien sûr que je fréquente des
enfants ce mes camarades ce qui peut y
avoir dans ma famille voilà c'est tout
les arrières des ordinaires vous avez eu
finalement exactement la vie dont vous
rêviez
quand vous étiez enfant justement vous
pensiez vous seriez comme ça une
militante politique pour syndicale quand
je rêvais quand j'étais enfant je devais
être comme les autres
enfant je rêvais de tas de choses je
rêvais de voir la mer finalement j'ai
réussi à l'avoir
nous ne réveillez pas d'être de
ressembler à une erreur oui
non je ne crois pas je crois pas
j'essayais d'en être une
et quand vous regardez votre parcours
vous avez réalisé ce que vous souhaitiez
vous êtes déçu je souhaiterais que les
chiffres donnés par monsieur de virieu
tout à l'heure les cats et demi pour
cent se multiplient par deux ou pas
trois mots bonheur serait ce un vrai
bonheur et ça serait vraiment formidable
que plusieurs millions de travailleurs
de ce pays votent pour la candidature
d'arlette l'aiguillé mais parler des
femmes vous êtes sensible au sort des
femmes qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous
faites pour les femmes d'algérie va
écouter mon combat bien sûr rejoint le
leur si on parle et spécialement des
femmes d'algérie
oui parce que c'est elle qui nous
touchent le plus peut-être en ce moment
oui ce que je fais d'abord j'ai je
soutiens autant que je peux
les manifestations je suis allé
récemment au rassemblement place de la
république
après l'assassinât de plusieurs femmes
en algérie et surtout je milite aussi
ici pour les aider parce que je crois
que les femmes algériennes qui veulent
se libérer aujourd'hui du code de la
famille de l'intégrisme du port du voile
ont besoin du soutien des femmes de ce
pays des femmes et des hommes de ce pays
donc de ce point de vue là effectivement
je soutiens leur combat et leur droit à
exister en tant que femme
et puis surtout je salue leur courage
parce que je crois que là bas en algérie
ils sont à la fois contre le pouvoir
dictatorial en place et contre la montée
des intégristes sont vraiment le fer de
lance des luttes pour en algérie donne
aux questions que c'est une fleur
alors puisque c'est la dernière en
sortant avant de sortir d'ici vous allez
enlever ce très léger maquillage qu'on
voit pour la première fois vous allez
regarder d'écouter je suis pas j'ai pas
trop pensé c'est pas trop de ça dont
j'espérais qu'on allait parler ici merci
christine clerc monsieur monsieur fidel
castro est actuellement à paris c'est
votre type d'homme monsieur castro
j'aime pas trop les barbus en général
mais sur le pont sont aujourd'hui sa
présente quelque chose contre contre
lequel je combats sur le fond je vais
dire deux choses par la police à la
venue de fidel castro fils del castro
pour moi il n'était pas un communiste
même si les américains finalement l'ont
poussé vers lure ce qui a été sa seule
chance finalement de pouvoir survivre
économiquement
est ce que je trouve vraiment indécent
et scandaleux c'est évidemment ce blocus
qui continuent à peser sur cuba qui
aggrave les difficultés économiques de
ce pays
mais il ya au moins une fidélité qu'il
faut reconnaître à fidel castro depuis
le début de la révolution cubaine et
croyez-moi on voit où vit mieux même
encore aujourd'hui à cuba que dans haïti
voisine pays capitalistes impérial le
niveau d'éducation le niveau de la santé
à cuba est bien supérieur à la plupart
des pays en voie de développement dans
la zone capitaliste alors de ce point de
vue là mais critique je les porterai
contrôle l'impérialisme américain jean
marie colombani
le programme de madame la grille bonjour
on va poursuivre un peu dans cette veine
là sur le la suite de fidel castro et
cuba où situez-vous l'idéal communiste
aujourd'hui sur la planète parce que
quand on vous pose la question de
l'idéal communiste ou dit
oui je sais bien on me dit il a fait
faillite en russie mais moi je n'ai
jamais cru au modèle soviétique
stalinien est-ce qu'on peut le voir à
l'oeuvre en chine aujourd'hui ce que le
modèle communiste chinois et le bon goût
est ce que le modèle communiste cubain
et le vix est ce qu'il existe évident
que le communisme n'existe pas sur cette
terre et que lorsque je dis que le
communisme ce sera possible en fait à
l'échelle du monde c'est à dire en
mettant en commun vraiment toutes les
richesses toutes les productions en
organisant la production au niveau
mondial non pas pour la satisfaction des
profits mais pour la satisfaction des
besoins des hommes et des femmes de
toute la planète parce qu'aujourd'hui
eh bien il ya des choses qui font
cruellement défaut dans les pays
développés où on y viendra peut-être
programme on pourrait faire beaucoup de
choses venir la situation dans les trois
quarts de l'humanité qui souffre de la
faim du sous développement du manque de
médicaments date d'un tas de choses qui
sont raisonnables qu'on peut régler à
condition qu'on change complètement
l'économie est ce que et qu'on produise
vraiment d'une autre façon que je
pouvais mais au niveau mondial justement
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
considérer que en gros dans les années
60 il y avait deux habitants sur trois
de cette planète qui était dans le
dénuement et qu'aujourd'hui années 90 il
y à un habitant sur trois qui est dans
le dénuement
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
considérer que cette plante là existe
cette pente la vertu la mieux avant vers
un certain progrès et est ce que cette
news est ce progrès vous convainc que
malgré tout l'économie telle qu'elle
fonctionne a quand même quelques mérites
ou bien est-ce que vous balayer jusqu'en
valais vraiment les
la vie pour vous ces statistiques si ces
punks
vous savez sur 30 ans si on regarde les
chaussures transit moi je viens dans un
sens très bien qu'on discute je veux
bien qu'on discute de chiffres je sais
pas on voit plein de reportages en ce
moment à la télévision française pour
dire que la misère s'accroît aux états
unis que 15% de la population est en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté en france
on compte combien 3 millions de chômeurs
officiels un peu plus + 3 millions de
rassembler le plus trois millions de
gens marginalisés rmistes en stage qui
travaille quelques heures quelques jours
par semaine c'est à dire 6 millions de
gens qui sont dans la pauvreté qui sont
dans le besoin qui n'ont pas
suffisamment pour manger pour se loger
pour se soigner alors vos 1/3 2/3 je ne
sais pas moi j'ai pas exactement ni la
même impression ni les mêmes chiffres
j'ai l'impression que la misère
s'agrandit qu'il ya un aux portes des
épidémies énorme pas seulement le sida
en afrique de tout un tas de maladies
qu'on ne soigne pas parce que produire
ces médicaments ça serait produire sans
faire de profit alors il ya un tas de
maladies qu'on connaît qu'on peut
soigner qu'on ne soigne pas parce que il
ya la moitié des habitants de l'afrique
plus qui n'est pas solvable pour payer
ses médicaments
peut-être pour ce pour vous c'est une
élévation du niveau de vie mais à qui on
le doit à qui on le doit en plus cette
élévation
est-ce que effectivement parler de cuba
tout à l'heure bah oui cuba avait au
moins réglé le problème de la faim dans
l'île et ça vous paraît plus important
que le problème de la liberté
s'agissant de cuba je sais pas si j'ai
pu si on discute de cuba maintenant je
suis au volant
je saisis au vol votre remarque il est
plus important d'aller vers le bien-être
sans la liberté que d'aller vers le
bien-être aux dépens de la liberté
puisque vous citez cubain il peut pas y
avoir de bien être sans liberté
évidemment mais la première condition du
bien-être ou du mieux-être c'est quand
même d'avoir un quad avoir de quoi
manger d'avoir de quoi s'éduquer et se
soigner c'est la première condition même
pouvoir pouvoir exercer une petite once
de liberté de toute façon maintenant si
vous pensez que oui à cuba il ya un
parti unique
j'ai toujours combattu ça je suis pas
d'accord avec ça je suis mais est ce que
vous croyez que nous vivons vraiment
dans les pays développés en démocratie
est ce que c'est la démocratie
délire tous les cas de cinq six sept ans
ça dépend des mandats et des élections
délire des hommes qui finalement une
fois élus vont remiser leurs promesses
aux vestiaires et puis vont surtout
servir les intérêts des possédants des
grands capitalistes des grands trusts
mondiaux qui veut en réalité se paye des
hommes politiques pour pouvoir mener
tranquillement leurs affaires à l'ombre
de l'état et avec l'argent de l'état
alors alors c'est peut-être ça pour vous
la démocratie mais je pense plus je
ferais remarquer que la démocratie elle
n'existe pas dans les pays capitalistes
des trois quarts du globe
je continue même si j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est pourtant à cette règle du jeu
là que vous participez aujourd'hui en ce
moment c'est à 17 règles du jeu
démocratique entre guillemets puisque
vous êtes candidate à une élection et
quelle élection et bien sûr et j'espère
bien que dans tous les pays qu'ils
soient un peu démocratique un peu plus
un peu moins ou beaucoup ou pas du tout
les militants révolutionnaires tente de
se servir de tous les moyens
effectivement pour faire entendre leur
leur langage pour donner les solutions
on y viendra peut-être avait sa mission
vous dites justement les changements
fondamentaux ne sont jamais sortis des
élections donc je voudrais savoir
comment vous voyez les changements
fondamentaux à venir pour la france ou
souhaitable pour la france après
le 7 mai prochain donc à partir du 8 mai
et comment voyez vous les choses se
déroulaient est ce que le pays est lourd
j'allais dire d'une explosion sociale
que vous voyez survenir quoi qu'il
arrive
ou est-ce que nous entrerons à nouveau
dans un cycle élections présidentielles
état de grâce et ainsi de suite
étals grâce pour le nouvel élu et ainsi
de suite les changements fondamentaux
ils sont évidemment jamais venue des
élections si les travailleurs en 36
obtenu les congés payés des
augmentations de salaires s'étaient pas
ce groupe à grâce au gouvernement de
front populaire c'était grâce à la grève
générale et en 68 c'est la même chose
le peu qui a été obtenu l'augmentation
du smic de 30 % un certain nombre de
choses dans les entreprises ça a été par
une grève générale qui a suffisamment
d'ailleurs inquiétée de gaulle pour
qu'il se réfugie dans les bras du
général massu pendant deux jours on l'a
vu partir en hélicoptère en allemagne ce
qui prouve d'ailleurs que certains
hommes politiques sont des fois assez
lucide sur les le fait que les
changements fondamentaux viennent plus
des luttes de la classe ouvrière qui ont
peut-être fait j'essaye de répondre
complètement lui-même s'il ya plusieurs
questions dans ce que vous me demandez
je ne suis pas prophète
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que des
luttes y en a en ce moment pendant que
nous parlons encore s'il y aller le
personnel de l'edf cas ce qu'est ce
trailer directeur je crois toute la nuit
pour obtenir une création d'emplois de
35 postes ce qui est très important dans
la période actuelle que les travailleurs
interviennent pour des créations
d'emplois on a eu toute la semaine
dernière des débrayages massifs sully
parmi plusieurs milliers d'ouvriers à
renault flins pour des augmentations de
salaire alors c'est tous les jours qu'il
y en a effectivement des conflits est ce
que ces conflits convergeront pour créer
vraiment un mouvement d'ensemble qui
seul sera de nature effectivement à
faire céder le gouvernement et le
patronat
ça je ne peux pas répondre je peux
simplement vous dire que moi je le
souhaite contrairement à beaucoup
d'hommes politiques qui eux le craignent
donc dans la dent
l'idée que vous avez des changements
justement et de la façon dont ces
changements peuvent survenir vous dit
toujours il n'y a qu'un seul agent du
changement c'est le prolétariat
où situez-vous les frontières du
prolétariat aujourd'hui comment
définissez vous puisque vous avez
l'habitude de critiquer ceux qui ceux
qui disent que le prolétariat
n'existe plus oui aussi une terre
régulièrement le prolétariat dans la
presse y compris dans votre journal
quand j'ai vu ça récemment et ben je
crois que ça amuse beaucoup les
travailleurs ce genre de choses ils ne
lisent pas forcément mais quand on leur
raconte
il trouve que il trouve que bon sans
doute les journalistes se rendent pas
compte qu'ils fabriquent leur voiture
qui fabriquent leurs chaussures qui
fabriquent leurs vêtements qui prépare
les plats surgelés qui feront réchauffer
dans leur micro ondes qui conduit les
autobus dans les quartiers difficiles
qui soignent les malades dans les
hôpitaux qui produit des voitures de
l'acier même s'il ya plus beaucoup de
sidérurgistes dans ce pays et c'est
alors la classe ouvrière
elle existe la classe ouvrière elle elle
n'est quoi elle n'exploite personne
contrairement au patronat donc est ce
que par rapport à ces demandes dire par
rapport à ces problèmes étaient aux
définitions vous donnez vous êtes
surprise ou non de par exemple du score
que peut faire un front national par
rapport à la façon justement dont le
prolétariat peut ressentir les problèmes
de vie quotidienne sécurité immigration
conditions de vie dans les quartiers
difficiles etc
et au bout de la route ce vote pour le
pour l'extrême droite envie de revenir
sur une fable qui consiste à dire que
c'est la classe ouvrière qui vote le pen
il ya sûrement malheureusement des
travailleurs assez inconscient pour
voter pour un ennemi des travailleurs
mais on vote beaucoup le pen dans
certains beaux quartiers de la capitale
de neuilly ou d'un certain nombre de
villes où ils ont peut-être jamais vu ce
que c'était qu'un travailleur immigré
est bien souvent des transferts de voix
dans certaines villes d'heure du rpr ou
de l'udf vers le front national
maintenant sur le fond si
malheureusement effectivement il ya des
travailleurs abuser par le pen parce que
c'est tellement plus facile
de désigner l'étranger comme le bouc
émissaire c'est quand même une vieille
recette de l'extrême droite
plutôt que de s'attaquer au patronat ce
que bien sûr le pen ou un de villiers ne
font pas évidemment jeudi de villiers
parce que ce n'est pas parce que c'est
le même langage en réalité alors
effectivement les travailleurs ont tort
mais je vous dirais que ce problème là
il serait sous vide dans la classe
ouvrière pour revenir deux secondes sur
flins vous savez quand aujourd'hui les
travailleurs de places bats et toutes
nationalités confondues toutes couleurs
de peau confondues et ils ont bien plus
de pouvoir dans leur lutte pour peser
justement sur les décisions sur ces
augmentations de salaire qui serait
nécessaire aux travailleurs aujourd'hui
mais pas 2% de 1000 à 1500 francs c'est
ça qui manque aux travailleurs
aujourd'hui
croyez-moi le pen il existe plus dans
ces cas là et la solidarité ouvrière
elle joue à plein alors sur le patronat
justement il y a en ce moment une
affaire importante qui se développe et
qui est la mise en examen donc du patron
du deuxième groupe industriel français
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
dans ses affaires d'une globalement je
façon générale on s'en prend plutôt aux
hommes en l'espèce à un homme alors
qu'il vaudrait mieux mettre en cause un
système où une mécanique ou bien est ce
que vous considérez que ce qui se passe
au fond c'est justice ben oui c'est
justice ça c'est sûr encore que je sais
pas je veux pas trop plein de monsieur
soir de ce qui va lui arriver
pour l'instant il peut plus diriger son
groupe ce qui va continuer sans lui ce
qui prouve d'ailleurs qu'on peut pas se
passer de travailleurs dans les
entreprises mais les patrons on peut
très bien s'en passer
et à ce propos la ce que je voudrais
dire justement c'est que oui votre
question c'est est-ce que ce qu'il faut
c'est remettre tout en cause tout le
patronat pas évidemment évidemment qui a
pas que alcatel qui profitent de
l'argent de l'état non seulement
simplement pour exister parce que tous
ces gens qui nous vend aujourd'hui le
libéralisme à tous crins n'existe bien
souvent de fond du profit que parce que
il ya les commandes de l'état alors
quand en plus comme monsieur soir
apparemment on a carrément puiser dans
la caisse de france télécom eh bien oui
c'est grave c'est bien plus courants en
réalité qu'on le croit et la seule façon
qui permettrait vraiment de le savoir
ce serait que les travailleurs aient le
contrôle de la comptabilité des
entreprises des comptes en banque des
dirigeants de ces entreprises
et puis pas seulement les travailleurs
de l'entreprise les associations de
consommateurs les associations d'usagers
qu'est réellement un contrôle de la
population sur ces gens qui en réalité
décide de tout y compris de la politique
du pays merci jean marie que l'on va
dire on enchaîne tout de suite avec
alain duhamel
bonjour madame bonjour mais si cette
société dont vous rêvez d'en vous venez
de parler est ce que vous croyez que
vous la verrez de votre vivant
je l'espère mais vous le croyez vous
savez ce qu'est ce que vous souhaitez
williams pierre sueur et voyez je sais
pas si aujourd'hui enfin on veut
absolument me prendre pour une impro
fait quelqu'un qui vit dans le marc de
café
c'est pas le bout de patience demain
jeudi je le soin je le souhaite je
souhaite le vivre et si je ne vis pas
juste que je suis persuadé c'est que
d'autres le vivront bien évidemment à
bien sûr on peut avoir malheureusement
la barbarie plutôt qu'une société
communiste au sens de communautaire au
sens du partage et oui effectivement les
idées dominantes aujourd'hui vont plutôt
dans ce sens là dans le sens des idées
réactionnaires dans le sens du fait que
la classe ouvrière doit être tout
disposé à accepter n'importe quelles
conditions travaillent où on culpabilise
ceux qui ont un emploi alors dix ans
mais il y à des chômeurs à vos portes
vous devez accepter n'importe quel
horaire n'importe quel salaire donc vous
voyez que c'était pas simplement du marc
de café je vous demandais non mais je
peux pas répondre
est ce que je verrai la révolution je
l'espère
il ya eu ça s'est terminé il ya quelques
heures un sommet très important qu'elle
participe et françois mitterrand à
copenhague dont l'objectif jeu bien
l'objectif était d'essayer de voir s'il
était possible de lutter contre la
pauvreté dans le tiers-monde et le
président français a lancé une
apostrophe c'était sa dernière
intervention publique de genre sur le
thème il faudrait qu'ils aient un
contrat entre les pays riches et les
pays pauvres et notamment qui est un
quota de ressources sociales réellement
affecté aux gens est ce que c'est le
genre de chose qui vous paraissent
purement verbale ou est-ce que ça vous
paraît aller dans le bon sens bon
écouter des discours comme ça on a
entendu des dizaines des centaines c'est
régulier tout le monde se rappelle riou
je crois il y a deux ans on devait faire
tellement de choses pour l'environnement
pour la planète et où deux ans après je
crois pas le moindre centime n'a encore
été versé par aucun des gouvernements
qui se sont engagés à faire quelque
chose pour l'environnement
alors ce qui s'est passé là copenhague
va être de la même eau exactement comme
les promesses de mitterrand 80 comme les
promesses de chirac de balladur ou de
jospin aujourd'hui
alors puisque vous parlez de françois
mitterrand il va terminer son deuxième
et dernier septennat
quel bilan est ce que vous essayez de
faire je veux dire pas pas le sens
global on imagine trop facilement
mais est-ce qu est-ce qu au fond dans
son bilan il ya des choses qui vous ont
plu ou pas vous savez il faut remonter
vraiment au 3 ou 3 aux six premiers mois
de 80 pour trouver l'abolition de la
peine de mort les 39 heures la retraite
à 60 ans alors il nous reste l'abolition
de la peine de mort l'artère dans 60 ans
on en parle de moins en mois puisqu'il
faut plus d'années de cotisations livre
blanc commandé sous rocard et puis
appliquée sous balladur
et puis les 39 heures
oui on sait plus trop si on les assure
les a pas on voit l'union patronale de
la métallurgie cusack et même plus
l'horaire de fixer du touquet il ya des
contrats individuels entre les
travailleurs et les salariés et puis
ensuite des 82 on a eu le blocage des
salaires les licenciements la sidérurgie
avec les dizaines de milliers
dissentiment l'automobile on a eu les
attaques contre la classe ouvrière et
peut-être que j'en veux le plus à
l'union de la gauche c'est d'avoir remis
au goût du jour finalement le patronat
le profit la spéculation boursière en
disant aux travailleurs que tout ça
c'était incontournable c'était
formidable
ce qui fait que les travailleurs ils ont
pas vu différence entre la droite et la
gauche est qu'aujourd'hui effectivement
ils sont désillusionnés
ils étaient démoralisés parce que je
crois qu'ils sont en train de retrouver
le moral
les luttes qu'il y ait en ce moment le
montre mais je crois aussi qu ils vont
être beaucoup moins après à faire
confiance à toutes ses promesses qui
sont trahis dès qu'on est élu et alors
si vous deviez cette fois-ci et créant
une phrase
enfin en quelques mots la façon dont
vous regardez les 14 années
mitterrandisme vous diriez quoi quelques
mots oui oui bon je dirai ce que les
sidérurgistes lorrains disait des 84
mitterrand tu nous as trahis mauroy tu
nous as trahis alors il ya deux ans un
nombre de candidats de gauche qui sont
en lice aujourd'hui il ya notamment
robert hue le candidat communiste
il y a certains points de son programme
qui correspondent à vos objectifs par
exemple l'augmentation immédiate des bas
salaires est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils attendent et
alimentation des salaires parce que je
crois que c'est pas le problème de
revendiquer ou de mettre dans un
programme
l'augmentation des salaires nous ne
l'obtiendrons quand nous battant et si
nous nous battons il faut prendre les
revendications qu'on est estimée par les
travailleurs dans toutes les entreprises
de 1000 à 1500 francs de perte du
pouvoir d'achat depuis le fameux blocage
correspond assez à ce que
dit de son côté robert hue alors ma
question c'est ma question c'est est-ce
qu'au fond vous sur le plan social je
dis pas ce plan idéologique ni théorique
mais sur le plan social est-ce que vous
vous sentez quand même une sorte de
cousinage ou de parenté avec lui je
crois que sur les salaires effectivement
on chiffres le même montant je crois que
je suis la seule à dire différemment de
tout le monde sur les solutions à
apporter
je crois que je suis la seule à dire
aujourd'hui qu'il faut réquisitionner
les entreprises qui suppriment des
emplois les entreprises qui licencient
et en premier lieu bien sûr celles qui
font des bénéfices et qui continue à
avoir des plans sociaux des plans de
licenciement je crois que les dernières
analyses et oui c'est une forme de
nationalisation mais sans indemnité ni
rachat
c'est une réquisition c'est une
expropriation sans indemnité ni rachat
et faire fonctionner les entreprises je
le répète sous le contrôle des
travailleurs sous le contrôle de la
population
décider de ce qu'il est bon de produire
y compris de produire sans profit parce
qu'on peut produire sans trophy vous
savez on nous révèle là entre le
portefeuille d'actions de monsieur
balladur et les salaires et les salaires
ou d'obligation de sicav monétaires les
le cumul qui l'avait qui lui faisait
entre conseillers de geci ces indemnités
gagner je crois cent soixante seize
mille francs par mois etc
alors on voit dans les affaires soient
pineau valencienne on voit dans la liste
des fortunes qui sont publiés
aujourd'hui qu' il ya eu beaucoup de
profits pendant que la classe ouvrière
était en train de mourir à petit feu
dans ce pays et bien ses profits il faut
les réquisitionner
il faut qu'ils servent à créer des
emplois à créer des biens utiles à
construire des logements à améliorer
leurs réseaux dans les banlieues ou
autour des grandes villes de transport
faire des interconnexions il ya beaucoup
de choses qu'il faut faire mais il faut
en avoir la volonté
et ça ne peut passer que par reprendre
ce pouvoir à ceux qui sont en train de
mener
effectivement ce pays à la faillite
parce qu'ils préfèrent spéculer sur les
monnaies et sur les bourses de toutes
les places du monde plutôt que de se
poser le problème du en el keiy
aujourd'hui lorsque quelqu'un comme
robert hue mais aussi quelqu'un comme
lionel jospin dit qu'il faut distinguer
entre les grandes entreprises
internationales et les pme et que les
pme il faut à la fois leur présenter des
demandes bien entendu mais veillez à ce
que en même temps un risque pas d'être
mise en difficulté est ce que c'est une
différence que vous faites vous aussi ou
pas du tout moi je suis méfiante quand
on dit ça parce que j'ai toujours
entendu dire qu'il fallait sauvegarder
les intérêts des petits quand il
s'agissait de donner aux gros on
connaissait vous connaissez très bien
dans le monde agricole où on nous fait
toujours pleurer sur les difficultés des
petits paysans des petits agriculteurs
pour finalement donner beaucoup d'argent
aux gros de l'agriculture aux industries
agroalimentaires
c'est la même chose c'est la même chose
dans l'artisanat
je dirais qu'à pme et pmi alors le petit
artisan qui travaille avec quelques
ouvriers qui n'est pas plus payer que
qui ne gagnent pas plus que il a rien à
craindre d'ouvrir ses livres de comptes
et ses comptes en banque
il lui arrivera rien de la part des
révolutionnaires mais c'est ça qu'il
faut avoir c'est le contrôle est quand
même un petit patron
qui exploite recense 200 300 salariés
nous dit qu'il est en faillite et que ça
va pas nous demandons nous les
travailleurs le contrôle et la ville en
ce sens cette volonté que vous avez vous
le dit depuis le début de l'émission
d'un voir les travailleurs la population
tout le monde qui puise en permanence
vérifier contrôler surveiller voir si
c'est vrai si c'est faux et c'est est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que c'est un
sentiment qui est beaucoup partagé par
les électeurs ça cette volonté là de
plus en plus savez je vise et on parle
beaucoup du prix de l'eau actuellement
entre parenthèses mais on en parle
beaucoup plus d'accord on en parle
beaucoup il faudra une nation parce
qu'il nous reste plus que trois cas il
faudrait nationaliser ces compagnies
font beaucoup d'argent sur le dos des
consommateurs
enfin vous avez en commun aussi avec
robert hue oui certainement certainement
et oui mais alors il faut beaucoup se
méfier mais je crois que l'ex-homme
consommateurs font de plus en plus
attention
j'ai vu là une municipalité de l'essonne
où le maire s'étant aperçu que sur sa
facture d'eau il y avait une taxe qui
n'auraient pas dû y est s'est aperçu
chez +6 à la générale des eaux la
lyonnaise des eaux percevait comme ça
peu sûr surtout les consommateurs une
taxe qu'elle n'avait pas à percevoir
parce qu'il n'y avait même pas mais
croyez-moi faut faire sa publicité à ces
choses là parce que effectivement les
consommateurs quand ils s'aperçoivent de
ça ils ont envie de contrôler les coûts
entre entre le lionel jospin candidat
socialiste edouard balladur jacques
chirac est ce que vous voyez des
différences d'orientation ou est ce que
pour vous sont des variations autour du
même thème
oui ça je les dis c'est vraiment les
deux bouddhas même bâton ils ont
gouverné ensemble ils sont dans les
mêmes formations idée ce sont des hommes
du patronat se dit aussi les avec lionel
jospin pendant la même formation est
capable ou verts n'avaient que excusez
moi alors restants j'y avais pensé plus
avoir la nourriture voilà c'est pas ça
c'est là que
savez c'est impressionnant l'heure de
vérité donc je vais vous répondre
d'abord sa pâleur martyrisé je vais vous
répondre sur les deux de la même famille
politique
bon alors bon leur bilan le connaît on
les a vus au gouvernement les uns et les
autres
et j'ose pas aussi on l'a vu au
gouvernement et on l'a vu à vocation
nationale et on l'a vu mais l'éducation
nationale puis on l'a vu secrétaire du
parti socialiste à faire avaler aux
militants toutes les mesures
impopulaires
j'ai pas entendu que je sais pas
aujourd'hui 10 qui regrette tout ce qui
a été fait contre la classe ouvrière
quand il dit distribué autrement entre
les profits et les salaires quand il dit
réduire la durée du travail etc
ça vous paraît il est temps d'en
distribuer autres oui oui distribuer
notre vrai ben oui je les ai vus dans
son programme à profit les salaires
absolument vide laissé dans son
programme
j'y peux rien c'est pas moi je l'écris
jrda dire alors c'est quand même très
vague
elle évaluera si j'ai lu les mesures
très précises mesure de lionel jospin en
visite est finie alors vraiment
substance en 2008 des cadeaux au
patronat 5000 francs enfin exonération
des charges sociales sur les 5000
premiers francs si j'ai bien compris
jusqu'aux salaire égal à quatorze mille
francs alors moi je connais beaucoup
plus de travailleurs payés en dessous de
14 mille francs dont je pense que ça va
représenter des dizaines et des millions
de salariés pour lesquels le patronat
n'aura pas à payer de charges sociales
je vais demander avec l'autorisation de
forer simplement un chiffre un chiffre
premier combien il sera coupée avant la
non mais un chiffre
combien ce qu'il y a deux militants
lutte ouvrière un chiffre 2000 voilà
merci alain duhamel c'était donc l'heure
de vérité de madame arlette laguiller
candidats à de lutte ouvrière la
présidence la république madame
l'aiguillé qui participait pour la
première fois à l'heure de vérité
vous serez candidate nouveau en 2002
j'ai pas oublier la question
je crois qu'on aura fait bouger les
choses m
je vous souhaite un bon anniversaire
madame car samedi prochain vous aurez à
nantes plus dimanche prochain nous
recevons monsieur philippe séguin
président de l'assemblée ça les bras
droit du candidat chirac qui sera
particulièrement intéressant d'entendre
monsieur séguin dimanche prochain trois
jours après l annonce du projet européen
de monsieur chirac puisque chacun le
sait les deux hommes n'avaient pas pris
la même position au moment du vote du
traité de maëstricht dans dix minutes le
journal présenté par philippe lefait
bonne semaine à tous et à dimanche
prochain
[Musique]